oh did you get locked out
I'm afraid little Eric put a lock on the
door to keep me out I'm sure he has the
passcode written down here somewhere
[ __ ] my honey booboo and I'm a beauty
queen [ __ ] I'm fat as well and I
don't
Wow
Wow
Wow
hey kid do you like Jim Pokemon well
then you're gonna go wild Wow mom you
won you mom that's not enough mosquito
we have to act fast before the Freedom
House can if there is someone in this
town who knows someone who works at
Netflix then we have to find that person
today but we were gonna start our
franchise play with movies the super
Craig Netflix series comes later we can
start with the Netflix series you know
that's what freedom powers are thinking
but who in this town could have a
connection to Netflix it could be
anybody that is what we must find out
fast pass mosquito you're on ABS on all
node Freedom House activity human chitin
Fastpass see what you can learn about
their Pio is super Craig just I don't
know browse the internet or something
let's go [ __ ] friends uh-oh I think we
have an ordinary citizen snooping around
hey hey do not touch that that device
can blow up the entire Milky Way galaxy
Jesus [ __ ] mom the new kid is trying to
play with the kid with ultimate
destruction you be nice to all your
friends Eric be a good share good shower
it up off the [ __ ] galaxies stupid
[ __ ] look dude we already told you you
can't play you aren't a superhero you
don't have a costume you have any super
powers freedom pals are adding people to
their franchise we should be adding
people ours this dork like wearing a
little crown does this look like a
superhero to you
alright alright have a seat douchebag
back that galaxy Cube is a super
powerful artifact from space oh don't
touch it move along I'm on confidential
[ __ ] business
how'd you get there hey this dude
[ __ ] croaks dude dude take that
outside
not there that's mysterion seed not
there either stupid
alright in order to play superheroes you
have to have a superhero persona then
you can fill out your character sheet on
Kunta Graham do you have a crew see
Graham Paige huh boy you're not even on
Q Instagram have well I guess I can
create one for you I cannot believe a
boom Quincy so the first thing we need
to fill out on your character sheet is
your class you know what kind of
superhero are you
super-strong hero like the hooker
Captain America blaster with raised
powers like Cyclops
bestir oh yeah it's like a Blanche or
Quicksilver I like it
okay douchebag but now we need to find
out what terrible thing in your past
drives you is he douche all superheroes
have a compelling backstory it's from
that backstory that their powers gained
meaning let's take you back to when you
were just a child you lay awake that
night
like so many other nights you couldn't
sleep because you knew you weren't like
the other kids
you walked to the mirror
you looked in the mirror and you felt
alone and that's when it happens a loud
noise you swore you could hear your
mother calling for help
you left your room you left your room
seriously do you just walk through the
door already out in the hallway you saw
two intruders in front of your parents
door you had to stop them from hurting
your parents you knew you had the power
to stop them so for the first time you
called upon your speedster power as a
super-fast speedster hero you've bent
space-time itself to spring into action
with super speed you moved in closer to
the intruder to deliver a quantum punch
the guy closest to you you moved in and
punched him you use your punch attack on
the bad guy dude we're not getting
anywhere till you use the power once
it's Adams return to their original
positions the intruder realized when he
was up against damn we weren't expecting
a superhero to live here desperately the
intruder struck our hero take this
emboldened his fellow intruder moved
into the fray you don't scare us
superhero but the intruders were only
moving closer to their demise
you vibrate an every subatomic particle
to become an unstoppable high-energy
body
he became a high-energy body hey what's
the kid door now what charge
you only needed one turn to defeat the
hapless intruders first you gave the
second intruder a taste of your atoms
nothing quantum fists
come on you just did this one [ __ ] my
atoms with both intruders weekend there
was nothing they could do against they
hear his final strike a supersonic gasps
aah move he was just too speedy with the
intruder soundly defeated who thought
you were safe until my third massive
intruder into the fray bigger than the
other two intruders two bags ah ha I
just flushed one little [ __ ] now here's
one more before you could react we swung
in struck a Jew and fists into your
small body doing critical damage
we heard yes but the intruder had made a
critical mistake he piss you of
summoning the last of your strength you
tapped into your ultimate ability the
multiverse strike
the multiverse jack
nice and so you beat them all seem to be
okay but then you finally reached your
parents door but you saw when you open
that door changed your life forever and
led you to fighting crime you were too
late because when you open that door you
saw you saw your dad
[ __ ] your man
Wow that's a pretty heavy backstory you
fight crime because you never forgot the
night you weren't in time and you saw
your own father the man you trusted [ __ ]
your mom it's like a ripple in time you
can't have a change isn't it all right
now you need to go out into the town and
do superhero stuff you know help people
and fight crime and dumb [ __ ] like that
there's some starting costumes in the
wardrobe and remember if you ever want
to try out a different class just come
talk to me
and get that character she completely
filled out you're not playing with us
and tells you you
yeah
planet for takeoff
we were supposed to be a duo remember
tweet yeah I remember
so when I walked out on guna friends you
should've walked out with me I like
coded bread because you had your own
booby thank god you're here they're
really going at it
so for Craig I had to have movies before
wonder twinkles introduced and they do
sets otherwise y'all cool makes no sense
because you're a traitor tweek and now
you're with a group of super traitors
this was started by you by people who
thought there should be preferential
treatment to certain heroes we are the
ones who walked out of the [ __ ]
franchise mysterion all right you must
listen to me right now I'm speaking to
you telepathically get out of my head
tinny your franchise is going nowhere
face the truth and you guys are kind of
douchebags
he just caught his douchebags in my mind
he did fire you son of a [ __ ] back
[ __ ] could make deal with you
guys freedom pals of the future kid just
hope you realize that before it's too
late
another thing I like about Freedom House
is we take our goddamn turns
Oh Cartman's only working for himself
new kid sorry about this super Craig so
don't be a dick wig you're the one being
a dick
hmm well hard to go wrong with laser
right fighting for the wrong side
I'm not your worst nightmare I aspire to
be yeah
it's Craig hi I've ate super Craig time
holy crap yo Craig I hate it when you do
this I'll go without ready and not
before come and get me dick check it out
ha car stay out of the street damn kids
[ __ ] you dude it's civil wars dick clear
clear you think you're still on the
right side yes you're on the wrong side
of this bitchin
Oh
another thing I like about Freedom House
is we take our goddamn turns
I got punic you find the fly
it's Greg time I've ate super Greg guy
yeah mmm not to do more than that to
give you my top or shielding maybe
that'll knock some sense into you Yogi's
gonna kick your ass Freedom House
what
no kid I like the way you put
who need to get laser
good job you kid you're really getting
the hang of this anyway what about poo
oh [ __ ] come on whoo what happened Timmy
got away hey hey completely made to my
mind you okay no seriously you guys you
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of my brains huh I
grabbed him we fought for a little bit
but his mental powers are too strong so
we did all that for nothing
not quite I got to me cell phone you did
there's sure to be a lead on that let's
get this back to base super quick and
analyze it